like I just recently found out all that
[__] that's happening in massage parlers
but like you know 10 years ago I had no
clue I would go buy a massage par and go
oh that's where massage is there's
nothing bad going on here I wonder how
many places like that are like like
psychics what happens at psychics at 4
in the morning why are they open at 4 in
the morning I think psychics are open
late at night because hey it's a scam
and it's late at night they're drunk and
like maybe it's a girl who's driving
home and the guy texted her and she does
no should I text him back why is he
texting me so late that's kind of
disrespectful I don't know if he's the
one and she pulls into that psychic's
office and she's like I just need you to
tell me about my future and the psychic
is like I sense there's a problem a
romantic interest my boyfriend yes yes
there you're stressed there's something
deeply troubling you you're you're
confused I am confused yeah yes you're
confused there's something coming up
something's happening he wants me to
come over the house and [__] I don't
want to do it yes that's it there's a
thing that he's wanting you to do that
you're not so sure of he's the one is
that it yes oh my God that's what I said
when I was on the way over here and then
when he said you're not sure if he's the
one I'm like oh my [__] god is it
like written on my forehead how's it
possible he knows he [__] knew about
Mark he knew about our relationship
problems and he knew that I was on my
way over there wondering whether or not
he's the
one I don't think he's the one I don't
think he's the
one I think you're my favorite girl
voice guy you might be a [__] [__]
and hang out with your
friends how does this psychic
know